Hey Thoughty2 here,
1.
If you are feeling lonely in Japan, you can
rent a Japanese middle aged man for $10 an
hour.
Welcome, to RIF.
2.
The 4th richest man in the world, Warren Buffet,
is worth $58.3 Billion but still lives in
the house he bought for $31,500 in 1958.
3.
The sloppy handwriting of doctors kills more
than 7,000 people annually.
4.
Air jordan's shoes were banned by the NBA.
However, Jordan wore them anyway, because
Nike was willing to pay the fine each game.
5.
In 2008 there was a music festival called
'Festival of the fuck bands', where bands
such as Fucked Up, Holy Fuck and Fuck Buttons
performed.
It was held in Fucking, Austria.
Yes that is a real place.
6.
In Moscow, Russia, there are stray dogs that
ride the subway trains on the same schedule
every day.
7.
Each episode of Game of Thrones costs $6 million
to produce.
8.
If the U.S. cut its military budget by 85%
it would still have the largest military budget
in the world.
9.
Russia is the same size as Pluto.
10.
The record for the longest Facebook conversation
belongs to Dawar Kazi, who with his friends,
have commented 584,444 times on a Facebook
status update.
11.
It is estimated that the Earth's helium supply
will have run out by 2030 and party balloons
will cost about $90.